there are many appropriate places to put
a baby and none of them are microwaves
here's why one scene in the flesh has
viewers in an uproar The Flash is full
of surprises it's chock full of cameos
from some of the DC universe's most
beloved heroes and villains features
multiple narrative twists and also
here's a kicker has a scene where Barry
Allen puts a baby in a microwave and the
Internet only has one thing to say about
it
[Music]
the scene in question actually depicts a
few babies and a dog falling from the
sky in slow motion drawing a rescue
mission at a collapsing Hospital
explains that if Barry tries to move
humans extremely quickly they could get
sick or potentially die to navigate this
he has to use objects that are within
reach to move them the baby is heading
toward a flame the best way to save the
child put them in a microwave which
protects them from the heat yes this is
done to save the baby but some people on
the internet were disturbed by the whole
ordeal and they made their feelings
known on social media one to the user
was appalled that the scene which
features a CGI baby happens in the first
five minutes of the film while another
wrote The Flash putting a baby in a
microwave is an insane scene to even
think about filming like what the
is that idea
the baby sequence ultimately ends with
all of the infants on a stretcher safe
and sound thanks to Flash's heroic
efforts however it isn't sitting well
with lots of moviegoers some of whom
might not even see the film as a result
one potential moviegoer said I'm really
trying to go into The Flash movie
tomorrow with an open mind but people
are saying he's putting a baby in a
microwave and I'm just like I don't even
know at this point what's happening
elsewhere one person argued that the
microwave scene is merely one disturbing
element of a movie that's full of
questionable content one Twitter user
meanwhile pondered the possibility of
the scene being removed on the line
writing do you think DC is gonna have to
edit this out if a kid puts a baby in a
microwave because Flash didn't while the
scene is disturbing because of its
content it's also off-putting because of
how it looks one fan wrote on Reddit
that baby shower scene was downright bad
with its CGI I legit thought they had
toy dolls another user compared it to
the CGI used in the Twilight films to
bring renesmaid to life
he's got your eyes Bella
foreign
has received considerable criticism for
its lackluster CGI the feedback
compelled director Andy muskete to
publicly discuss how the film's unique
visuals were a creative Choice the
director told io9 the idea of course is
we are in the perspective of The Flash
everything is distorted in terms of
lights and textures it was part of the
design so if it looks a little weird to
you that was intended while some DC fans
were shocked by the scene others found
the sequence to be an inventive way to
show off the Flash's powers for some the
baby shower sequence was actually a
highlight one user even called it
probably the best moment in the whole
film like most of the creative choices
in the DC extended Universe the decision
to have the flash put a baby in a
microwave has proven to be controversial
he is hoping future installments don't
double down on it